and for me it's more like just trying to
like I have a movie out liyan's get
right now that's got it pretty much in
like a 95% african-american Latino cast
and it's not about it's just a hormone
it's a slasher movie and I just tell
people it's just like if you're watching
screen where it's like a bunch of pretty
white kids and there's like well not
even the first one they didn't have any
black people on the first one but you
know one of the later screams were
you're watching a bunch of pretty white
kids and they have like the one black
friend as our movies like you're just
focusing on all the pretty black and
Latino kids and they have a couple of
white friends so it's it's not that
you're making a movie that's about race
it's just you're casting a movie that's
just focusing on a different group of
friends than most of the horror films do
so I think that that that type of movie
in my humble opinion will actually reach
a wider market because again you know
white audiences just want to go see a
good horror movie you know like they
don't care what color they the
characters are and then people of color
who are horribly underrepresented in
horror films or your huge audience for
horror films we've just done all the
tests even at new line we did test
marketing back and you know the 90s and
it was like in all the major cities it
was like 50% you know the whole audience
is in all the major cities were
african-american Latino and it's such a
horribly underserved market that they'll
go to see the movie numerous times
because they've never seen themselves
represented on screen it's just people
and regular horror fans and not Rick
it's awful
well I'm trying to be so PC right now
screw that I know snowflake you know but
you know a horror fan white fans
and songs is a good slasher movie
they're gonna go see a couple times too
so that's gonna be a really good kind of
social experiment and it's taken me like
20 you know I've been trying since I I
tried to have a you know black lead and
one of the final destination movies and
it hasn't never happened and um you know
so it's taking me like yeah it's taken
me 20 some years to like finally get a
movie going you know so it's it is it's
funny when we when we talk about you
know were races and is it an American
it's like oh we're you know we voted for
Obama so we're post-racial now and
everything's hunky-dory and it's like
yeah it's that you know it like is cuz
you know Halle was pretty friggin
liberal but they they know what sells
and what won't sell and they know how
people like pigeonhole kind of movies
and sometimes they do underestimate
definitely they underestimate people's
and
in a way or what they'll go see but
there there's just also the hard reality
that you have to prove to them like I'm
gonna be like girl Triplett came out
with Jada Pinkett and Queen Latifah and
you know makes thirty million dollars
opening weekend him they're like wow you
know and Wonder Woman comes out directed
by a woman and about a woman superhero
what they act so surprised and it's like
nobody wants to take a chance on
something that's different so you have
to you have to find that person that
will or that studio that will and then
once you do I guarantee you once this
movie comes out there's gonna be a whole
bunch of you know slash your horror
films that are like you know heavily
like diverse cast so so again it's kind
of like the quiet fight you know I
haven't been running around like you
know yelling after every fun listen
comes out when I wanted a black
character to be the lead and they
wouldn't like I you know that's not
gonna do me any good that's just gonna
upset people and make people think that
I'm like crying grace you don't say like
it's not gonna be productive so you just
kind of have to put your put your best
foot forward to put your money where
your mouth is and try to to you find
people that like kind of get behind a
movie like the one that we're doing now
so did you try to add a non-white
character to any of the final destiny
yeah and and what would happen they
would just cast a white person so they
you would write it into the script yeah
as to who this character was and then
when you saw the final product yeah yeah
I wasn't there okay yeah and it you know
it was Friday and the the the reality is
is internationally movies if the lead is
a person of color they don't sell as as
well internationally and you know I get
except for like you know like a Halle
Berry or Denzel Washington or there's
you know there's a there's there's like
maybe five names that will in certain
genres will sell internationally but you
know movie like get out comes out and it
makes a hundred million here and it only
cost like five million to make it's like
who cares what it makes internationally
like you're gonna make that money here
so there there is a little bit of
business reasoning behind it but a lot
of it's like until you you try to break
the mold you never know what the mold
you know you never know until you try to
break the mold and you know that's why I
think this last year with get out and
Wonder Woman we're so important is
because even though I even
I'm on my facebook before it came out
I'm like I'll bet my life that one was
gonna be one of the top-selling you know
superhero films of all time and it's
just because people don't they
underestimate how powerful of an impact
Lynda Carter had his Wonder Woman so
pretty much everybody you know in their
40s you know 50 you know and above and
you know late 30s anybody who kind of
grew up on singing Lynda Carter as
Wonder Woman loved that character and
she's been around forever and then you
got younger people meeting her in the
Justice League so I knew the movie was
gonna do like huge business but nobody
you know it's like when people say oh if
an openly gay actor were to play a you
know like James Bond nobody would
believe it I'm like why don't we try it
first you know like because I I think
people that go watch movies like know
that Robert Englund is not a you know
child molesting serial killer that wears
you know I'm sure I'm sure that they
know he's not like that in real life so
I don't know if this is it's funny so
you just try to make whatever changes
you can with your art and a lot of times
it doesn't even happen and again I work
in the horror genre so for you know
again it's it's even more it's even
harder to try to like you know you don't
want it you can't get too high-minded in
you know in a horror film you can you
know again you can try to again make
strong female characters you know make
interesting dynamics between between
everybody you know show diversities of
just people of any like religion or
background and you know you can try to
put all that in your movie but a lot of
times that ends up getting out of your
hands you know once you sell the script
so you just kind of again that's when
you learn to kind of let go and you know
be grateful you had a movie made you
know
you